Artificial general intelligence,
there's seems to be two camps of people,
ones who are really working deep in it.
Like that's the camp I kind of sit in.
And a lot of those folks tend to roll their eyes and just not engage in tiny
discussions in the future.
They're idea is saying it's really hard to do what we're doing and it's just
really hard to see how this becomes intelligent.
And then there's another group of people who say,
yeah,
but B,
you're being very shortsighted that you may not be able to do much now,
but the exponential,
the hard takeoff overnight,
it can become super intelligent and then it'll be too late to think about.
Now the problem with those two camps,
as with any camps,
Democrat republic,
any camps is they don't seem that'd be,
seem to be talking past each other as opposed to both have really interesting
ideas.
If you go back to the analogy of a touch of death,
a of this,
this idea of MMA,
right?
So I'm the,
in this analogy,
I'm going to put myself in the UFC for a second.
Uh,
in this analogy,
I'm,
you know,
like ranked in the top 20.
I'm working really hard.
My dream is to become a world champion.
I'm training three times a day.
I'm really working.
I'm an engineer.
I'm trying to build my skills up.
And then there's other folks that come along like Steven Seagal and so on that
kind of talk about other kinds of martial arts,
other ideas of how you can do certain things.
And I think,
I think Steven Seagal and could not mine beyond to something.
I think we really need to be open minded like a inch.
The civil,
I think it talks in us or somebody talks as you know,
Ciga,
right?
Anderson Silva thinks Steven Seagal is,
I want to put this in a respectful way.
He Anderson Silva has a wonderful sense of humor and Anderson Silva is very
playful and he thought it would be hilarious if people believe that he was
learning all of his martial arts from Stacy's.
Got It.
He also loves Steven Seagal movies legitimately so treated him with a great deal
of respect.
He also recognizes that Steven Seagal actually is a master of Ikea.
He really does understand the Kido and was one of the very first Westerners that
was teaching in Japan,
speaks fluent Japanese,
was teaching at a Dojo in Japan and is,
you know,
a legitimate master of I kido.
Right.
The problem with that Quito is it's,
it's one of those martial arts that has merit in a,
in a vacuum.
They get few.
If you're in a world where there's no NCAA wrestlers or know judo players or no
Brazilian Jujitsu,
black belt or no,
um,
Moitai kickboxers,
there might be something to that Ikea stuff.
But in a world where all those other martial arts exist and we've examined all
the intricacies of hand to hand combat,
it falls horribly short.
Let's see.
This is the point I'm trying to make.
You just said that we've investigated,
uh,
all the intricacies.
You said all the intricacies of hand to hand combat.
I mean,
you're just speaking,
but you want to open your mind to the possibility that I kito has,
uh,
some techniques that are affected are affected.
Yeah.
When I say all that's you're,
you're,
you're correct.
That's not a correct way of describing it,
right?
Because there's always new moves that are being like for instance,
um,
in this,
uh,
recent fight between Anthony Pettis and Tony Ferguson,
Tony Ferguson actually used wing Chung in a fight.
He,
he trapped one of Anthony Pettis his hands and hit him with an elbow.
they basically used a technique that you would use on a wing Chung dummy.
And he did it in an actual and world class,
mixed martial arts fight.
And I remember watching it.
Wow,
go on this crazy motherfucker actually pulled that off.
Cause that's,
it's a technique that you just rarely see anybody getting that proficient at it.
That,
that fights in MMA and Ferguson is it extremely creative and open minded guy.
And he figured out a way to make that work,
you know,
worldclass fight.
So,
and let me then ask you the question.
There's,
there's these people who still believe quite a lot of them that there is this
touch of death,
right?
So do you think it's possible to discover no through this rigorous scientific
process that is MMA that started pretty recently?
Do you think,
not the touch of death,
but do you think we can get a 10 x improvement in the amount of power the human
body can,
can generate in and punching?
No,
certainly not.
10 X.
I think you can get incremental improvements,
but it's all based entirely on your frame.
Like if you're a person that has very small hands and narrow shoulders,
you're kind of screwed.
There's not really a lot of room for improvement.
You can,
you can certainly get incremental improvement and your ability to generate
power,
but you'll never be able to generate the same kind of power as say a guy with a
very big frame like a Brock Lesnar or Derrick Lewis or,
um,
you know,
anyone who has,
there's like classic elements that go with,
uh,
being able to generate large amounts of power,
wide shoulders,
large hands.
There's a,
there's a lot of characteristics of the human frame itself.
Um,
those,
even those people,
there's only so much power you can generate.
And we pretty much know how to do that correctly.
So the,
the way you're talking about as a martial arts expert now,
it's kind of the way a lot of the experts
in robotics and AI talk about AI and when the topic of touch of death has
brought up,
now the analogy is not perfect.
I tend to use probably too many analogies is we maybe know the human body better
than we know the possibility of Ai.
I assume so.
Right.
Cause the possibility of AI is basically limitless.
Once AI starts re redesigning itself,
it's not obvious that that's true.
Our imagination allows it to be true.
When I,
I'm of two minds,
I am,
I'm both,
I can hold both believes that are contradictory in my mind.
One is that idea is really far away,
almost bordering and bs.
And the other is it can be there overnight and I think you could believe both of
those things.
So,
um,
hmm.
There's another,
uh,
quote,
from Barbara Wooden,
that's a poem I heard on a,
on a,
on a lecture somewhere that I really like,
which is,
it's from the champions of the impossible rather than the slaves of the
possible.
That evolution draws his creative force.
So I see all mosque as a representative of the champion of the impossible.
I see exponential growth of AI within the next several decades as the
impossible,
but it's the champions of the impossible that actually make the impossible
happen.
Why would a
exponential growth of AI be impossible?
Because that seems inevitable to me.
So it's not impossible,
Eh,
I'm sort of using the word impossible in meaning magnificent.
The feels very difficult.
Very,
very difficult.
We don't even know where to begin.
Rand.
Yup.
Like the touch of death actually feels,
I would see the touch of death is horse shit,
but see,
you're an expert.
Ah,
and they touch you in the chest,
but we don't have the ability in the body to generate that kind of energy.
How do you know that?
That's a good question.
Um,
it's never been done.
We understand.
How do you know it's never been done?
Okay.
There could be someone out there with magic that I,
that has escaped my,
my grasp.
No,
you've studied,
you've talked about with a Graham Hancock,
and he was talking about the history.
Maybe it was in Roman times.
There was that idea was discovered and then it was lost because weapons are much
more effective ways of,
uh,
of delivering damage.
Now I find myself in a very uncomfortable position of defending the concept as a
martial artist,
uh,
defining the concept of this sorts.
Did you study a Jujitsu and judo and wrestling,
wrestling,
the hard ones?
Those are the Jitsu.
Judo and wrestling.
Those are absolute martial arts in my opinion.
This is what I mean.
Like if you are a guy who just has a fantastic physique and incredible speed and
ridiculous power,
just you just can generate ridiculous power if you just are,
uh,
just a Pr,
you know,
who do you not Deontay wilder is,
yes.
Heavyweight champion.
The world boxer.
He's a fee.
You have,
what's his name?
Tyson fury fury.
On tomorrow it's going to feed it guys,
right?
Yes.
Oof.
Deontay wilder has fantastic power.
I mean,
he just knocks people flying across the ring.
He's just,
I think Deontay wilder,
if he just came off the street,
if he was 25 years old and no one ever taught him how to box it all,
and you just wrapped his hands up and had him hit a bag,
he would be able to generate insane amounts of force.
Now,
if you are a person that really didn't have much power and you had a box with
Deontay wilder,
and you were both of the same age,
and you are a person that knew boxing and you stood in front of Deontae,
it's entirely possible that Deontay wilder could knock you into another
dimension.
Even though he had no experience in boxing.
If he just held on you and hit you with a haymaker,
he might be able to put you out.
If you're a person who is,
let's say,
built like you an a guy who exercises who strong and then there's someone who's
I identically built like you who's a black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu and you
don't have any experience in martial arts at all.
You're fucked,
right?
Yes.
You're a person who's built like you who's a,
a guy who exercises and is healthy and you grapple the guy who is even stronger
than you and bigger than you,
but he has no experience in Brazilian Jujitsu.
He's still fucked.
Yeah.
That's the difference.
That's why I think Brazilian Jujitsu and judo and wrestling and particularly
those are absolutes in that you have control of the body.
Yes.
And once you grab a hold of a person's body,
there's no lucky triangle chokes in Jujitsu.
That's right.
Right.
But
I think,
uh,
I think I would say Jujitsu as the highest representative of that.
I think in wrestling and judo,
having practiced those,
I've never been quite as humble.
Does that have been in Jujitsu Jitsu?
Especially when I started,
I was like power lifting.
I was like,
I was a total meathead and you know,
130 pound guy or girl could tap you easily.
Yeah.
It's confusing.
It's very confusing in wrestling.
You can get pretty far with that head power.
Yeah.
And judo a little bit less.
So at its highest levels at if you go to Japan for example,
where they,
I mean the whole dream of judo is effortlessly throw your opponent,
but in,
you know,
if you go to gyms in America and so on,
there is some hard wrestling style gripping and just beating each other up
pretty intensely where we're not talking about beautiful tomatoes are these
beautiful throws.
We were talking about some scrapping some,
uh,
some wrestling style.
Yeah.
Yeah,
no,
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
Um,
my experience with Jujitsu was very humbling when I first started out.
I was,
uh,
I had a long background in martial arts and striking and uh,
even wrestled in high school.
And then I started taking Jujitsu and a guy who was my size and I was young at
the time and he was basically close to my age,
just mauled me.
And he wasn't even a black belt.
I think he was a purple belt.
He might've been a blue belt.
I think it was a purple belt.
Um,
and he just destroyed me.
Just did anything he wanted to meet,
choked me,
arm barred me just,
and I remember thinking,
man,
I am so delusional.
I thought I had a chance.
Right.
I thought just based on taking a couple classes and learning what an Armbar is
and then being a strong person who has a background in martial arts that I would
be able to at least hold him off a little bit.
No.
And this is,
uh,
that's so beautiful that I feel lucky to have that had that experience of having
my ass kicked.
And Philadelphia is where I came up with.
Because in science,
you don't often get that experience in the space of ideas.
You can't,
uh,
you can't choke each other out.
You can't beat each other up in science.
And so it's easy to go your whole life.
I have so many people around me telling me how smart I am.
Uh,
there's no,
uh,
way to actually know if I'm smart or not cause I think I'm full of bs and in the
same,
uh,
I in the same realm is as fighting.
There's no,
it's a will.
Hixon Gracie said it means the,
or some of the Sala bearer or somebody that the math doesn't lie.
There's this deep honesty in it that was,
um,
really grateful.
Almost like wanting,
you know,
you talk about bullies are you talk about,
or even just my fellow academics could a benefit significantly from training a
little bit.
I think so too.
It's uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's a beautiful thing to almost,
I think has been talked about in high school sort of requiring it.
Yeah.
Many times.
I think it's a more humbling sport to be honest than wrestling cause you could,
in wrestling,
like I said,
get away with,
with some muscle.
It's also what martial arts are supposed to be in that a small person who knows
technique can beat a big person who doesn't know the technique.
That's right.
That's what we always hoped for.
Right.
When we saw the Bruce Lee movies and Bruce Lee who was a smaller guy,
I can beat all these bigger guys just cause he had better technique that is
actually real in Jujitsu.
And it's one of the only martial arts where that's a real,
yeah.
And I,
uh,
I have an in Philadelphia has started,
you had Steve Maxwell here,
right?
Sure.
That's kind of where the,
that was the spring of Jujitsu in Philadelphia.
He was one of the very first American black belts and Jujitsu like way back in
the day,
I believe he was a black belt in the very early nineties.
Yeah.
Um,
when Jujitsu was really just starting to come to America and he had a Max
Marseilles exercise in Philadelphia.
It's still there.
And then I tried to balance,
which is,
uh,
a few Gracie folks,
which she's filming Clarice,
Rick Burglaries,
Josh Vogel,
Brothers.
So all those,
I mean,
especially Vogel brothers,
a couple black balls that come up together is there.
Well,
they're smaller,
the little guys.
And I think those were the guys that really humbled me pretty quickly.
Well,
little guys are the best to learn technique from.
Yeah.
Because they can't rely on strength.
There's a lot of really big,
powerful,
you know,
250 pounds,
you Jitsu guys who never are going to develop the sort of subtlety of technique
that some like,
uh,
what the May out brothers like smaller guys who just,
they've from the very beginning,
they've never had an advantage in weight and size and so they've never been able
to use anything but perfect technique.
Eddie Bravo is another great example of that too.
You know,
he,
he competed in the 140 pounds,
145 pound class.